[Music]
on this Friday night new claims of
foreign interference the liberal MP
accused of accepting support from the
Chinese government with the prime
minister's senior staff knew Global News
investigates
vowing Victory the Ukrainian president
reflects on a year of Russia's war
and as cynicism over beijing's pitch for
peace plus snow way the unusually cold
weather blanket in California the fears
of what else is in the forecast
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
after a months-long investigation into
alleged attempts by Beijing to interfere
in Canada's Democratic process Global
News can reveal new allegations emerging
from an ongoing probe by the Canadian
Security intelligence service
intelligence sources tell global news
that investigators have been tracking
current Ontario liberal MP Han dong
since the summer of 2019. and those
sources say he is one of 11 Toronto area
riding candidates believed to be
supported by Beijing in the lead-up to
that Year's federal election and alleged
to be an affiliate in China's election
interference networks tonight Mackenzie
gray has the New Revelations in This
Global News investigation Mackenzie
pharah after an eight-month
investigation intelligence sources have
told global news that current liberal P
Han dong is alleged to have been
supported by Beijing in 2019 and the
prime minister's senior staff were
warned about it reliably read since 1993
scoring the liberal nomination in Don
Valley North has been harder than
winning a general election recently but
instead of leaning on his connections as
a former Ontario MPP sources say Han
dong had help from the Chinese consult
in Toronto to become the 2019 liberal
candidate in the riding through a
combination of ceases documents and
intelligence sources Global News has
learned the consulate allegedly sent two
busloads of Chinese Canadian seniors to
the dawn Valley North liberal nomination
meeting and those seniors knew who to
vote for because Dawn's name was written
on their arm sources also say ceases
suspected that Chinese International
students with faked addresses were bused
in and told by the PRC consulate to
support their preferred candidate if
they wanted to maintain their student
visa status dong denied allegations he
was helped by Beijing calling them false
accusations that slander me and the
community I represent my nomination in
2019 was open and followed the rules the
Liberal Party of Canada echoed that
nomination was open adding dong was
elected by registered liberals in a race
that followed their National rules
Global News has not verified the
allegations against dong but even if
they are found true political parties
are private organizations and can set
their own rules non-canadians can vote
in Liberal nomination races if they live
in the riding and our party members this
is fandang I'm the liberal candidate for
down my leader dong won the nomination
but he still needed Justin Trudeau's
stamp of approval to carry the liberal
Banner in the Suburban Toronto riding
one with a sizable diaspora of Chinese
Canadians a senior intelligence official
told Global News ceases shared their
concerns about Dong in late September
2019 during a classified briefing with
senior Liberal Party Staff who hold
security clearances in that meeting
cesus urged them to rescind Dong's
nomination Caesars was concerned that
Han dong was connected to the People's
Republic of China for an interference
Network in Canada an official with
knowledge of the brief told Global News
despite the alleged warnings to his
staff Trudeau approved Dong's candidacy
during the election a top liberal
organizer even worn Dong's team that he
was allegedly a cease's Target according
to sources dong is still an MP today
Global News asked the prime minister's
office multiple questions including if
Trudeau New Dong was allegedly a thesis
Target but pmo didn't respond to any of
our questions saying there were so many
factual inaccuracies that it's not
possible to begin to even answer them
pharah
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie
with me now is investigative reporter
Sam Cooper he broke the first stories
about attempted Chinese interference and
has been working his sources on this for
months Sam let me start with what's your
understanding of why the liberal
candidate this liberal candidate Han
dong now an elected MP was the preferred
candidate for the Chinese Communist
Party
pharah our sourcing says the point of
China's interference is it wants
Canadian officials to favor China's
interests so China targets favored
candidates and by giving them
clandestine support and funding help
select them this creates a bond of
obligation so these Canadian politicians
won't criticize China on human rights
issues or they might support China on
big issues such as perhaps the case of
manwan Zhao and our Michaels imprisoned
in China for example with regards to Mr
Don specifically to be clear he has
denied the allegations but what our
sources say is that cesus called Don a
close contact of Toronto consulate
officials also in 2019 he allegedly met
with a senior Chinese Communist Party
official in New York state as part of
China's interference plot so the concern
is he is being directed by these
officials well the China the Prime
Minister says he's aware of Chinese
interference generally and knows it's a
serious issue even raised it when he met
Chinese president last year yet your
sources have told you that senior
officials in the prime minister's office
were given a classified briefing warning
one of their candidates was part of this
clandestine election interference
Network and urging them to rescind his
nomination but they didn't do that so
what's behind the disconnect there
pharah first of all I pressed the prime
minister's office but they would not
confirm they received this briefing but
my sources say Michael Chan a veteran
liberal politician who was a top Target
in these investigations and allegedly
promoted Don in 2019 is a significant
fundraiser for Trudeau's party and also
has the ability to recommend nomination
candidates in Toronto pharah Michael
Chan has denied the allegations but my
sources raised the question of whether
the Liberal Party may be downplaying
ceaseless warnings on Chen because of
the influence and success he has inside
the party Farah also my sources fear the
Prime Minister isn't addressing the real
issue here as we reported Caesars
believes elections are fixed in party
nominations so if China controls the
writings funding and Community volunteer
networks and successfully promotes the
candidate in a writing that's almost
always won by a certain party this is
akin to winning a seat in Ottawa Farah
explosive reporting I'm sure reaction
will start pouring in Sam Cooper in
Ottawa thank you Sam
[Music]
to Ukraine now on a day of commemoration
reflection and heartache it's been one
year since Russia launched its
full-scale Invasion upending the lives
of all who live there today ukrainians
wept at memorials for their tens of
thousands dead president valudamir
zielinski remained defiant vowing to
push for victory in 2023 he called this
day last February the longest day of Our
Lives saying every Ukrainian now has at
least one contact in their phone who
will never pick up the phone again but
histoically reminded the world Ukraine
did not raise the White Flag instead it
defended the blue and yellow
foreign
begins our coverage tonight and how the
world is marking this Grim anniversary
365 days of Anguish the people of
butcher bear deep wounds it was here
that the world saw some of the first
atrocities committed in the name of
Russia's so-called special military
operation an estimated 400 civilians
were killed some executed in the streets
they were hastily buried only to be
exhumed later to document their cause of
death and ID the bodies Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski said the
Terrible Things seen in this city after
the Russians fled were some of the
scariest for him of the full invasion
Russia and the world expected Kiev to be
seized in days and the government
overthrown yet a year later
may this be proudly proclaimed
everywhere Ukraine is alive
Ukraine
glory to Ukraine glory to the heroes
rang out in Saint Sophia Square soldiers
and families together commemorating what
zielinski coined the year of
invincibility
the conflict is the largest war on
European soil since the second world war
and led to Europe's largest Refugee
crisis the U.N estimates at least 12
million people fled their homes we need
to remind that it's important to win
it's important to send additional weapon
for Leopard 2 tanks are now in the hands
of the Ukrainian military courtesy of
Poland Canadian soldiers have been in
Poland training ukrainians to use the
modern tanks
her son was the last major city
liberated by Ukraine today the streets
mostly empty but here too people speak
of resilience
we survived bombardments didn't we we
survived the atrocities that commitment
to Country and belief that they will be
victorious is something that hasn't
faltered with time no one however
believes that the battles will get any
easier especially as Russia moves to
strengthen its relationships with Iran
and China far crystal commencing in
London thank you Crystal
in Russia signs of sympathy for Ukraine
on the anniversary of the invasion in
both Moscow and St Petersburg some
residents laid flowers and candles at
separate monuments of Ukrainian writers
between those two instances though more
than 15 people who were paying tribute
ended up being quickly detained by
police and other residents also felt
differently with some people grabbing
flowers and dumping them in the garbage
here in Canada prime minister Justin
Trudeau wasn't hiding his thoughts about
Russian President Vladimir Putin today
Putin is dangerous he is cowardly
and he is weak
his Brazen disregard for human life his
irresponsible rhetoric and his
willingness to inflict terrible violence
on innocent people may seem to have no
limits
but what is truly Without Limits
is the courage and resolve of those who
fight every day for their freedom
announced 32 million dollars in
additional support for Ukraine including
four more leopard two tanks additional
ammunition and a fresh round of
sanctions on Russia targeting 63
entities and 129 individuals and
Washington also announced extra two
billion dollars in security assistance
for Ukraine today and it also revealed
its own set of trade sanctions against
more than 100 entities inside and
outside Russia including two Canadian
companies
the Chinese government has unveiled its
own solution to end the war coming up
what Beijing is proposing and the
reaction plus help on the way Canada's
new relief for earthquake Rapids regions
of Syria and turkey
there are more questions over what role
China will play in the war as Beijing
tightens its alliance with Moscow
stoking fears it may help arm Russian
forces but China has now released its
own strategy for ending the war
unveiling a so-called peace plan calling
for an immediate ceasefire and an end to
sanctions against Russia Jackson prosco
looks at why the proposal is being met
with widespread skepticism
one of Russia's few allies emerged with
a proposal to end the war
China is willing to play a constructive
role in politically resolving the
Ukrainian crisis Beijing announced
instead of sharing its vast military
might with Russia
China wants to broker a comprehensive
ceasefire have peace talks and see an
immediate end to all sanctions on its
Ally Russia so we will look at the
principles of course but we will look at
them against the backdrop that China has
taken sites indeed China is no neutral
Observer Beijing refuses to condemn the
Russian invasion and maintains a
partnership Without Limits with Moscow
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
said he would still like to meet with
China's Xi Jinping in the future I think
that would be useful to our countries
and to Global Security
Ukraine says any peace plan must start
with the complete withdrawal of Russian
troops one year ago at the U.N security
Council western allies quickly rejected
China's proposal members of this Council
should not fall into the false
equivalency
of calling on both sides to stop
fighting no member of this Council
should call for peace while supporting
Russia's war on Ukraine and on the U.N
Charter with its plan Beijing seems to
be sending a message respecting
Ukraine's sovereignty means respecting
China's too especially when it comes to
the future of Taiwan and the growing U.S
military presence on China's doorstep
some country while stressing sovereignty
and territory Integrity on the Ukraine
issue is blatantly interfering other
countries Internal Affairs and
undermining their sovereignty and
territory Integrity China and Russia are
both clear they want a new multi-polar
world one that counters the power of the
US and NATO caught in the middle is
Ukraine where the year-long war is
increasingly a battle for the future
Global Order
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
storming through the
more troubling weather in the United
States as an unusual winter storm sweeps
through parts of California the system
has also triggered rare blizzard
warnings the first ones in decades in
areas around Los Angeles and San Diego
the heavy snow and dropping temperatures
are not the only concern either strong
winds and rain are also slamming the
region raising the risk of flash
flooding and most of Canada is under
some form of winter weather warning
tonight environment Canada's issued
extreme cold warnings for most of the
country including Newfoundland and
Labrador where the wind chill is
expected to make it feel more like -50
the bitter cold will also be felt across
all of Alberta and Saskatchewan where
the wind chill is expected to dip
somewhere between -40 and minus 50
degrees and BC is bracing to be blasted
with a record-breaking cold snap as well
now even with that blast of bitter cold
ottawa's Rideau Canal Skateway will stay
closed all winter that's the first time
that's happened and it's 53-year history
above seasonal temperatures have kept
the world's largest skating rink closed
all season the national capital
commission which maintains the rank
requires the ice to be 30 centimeters
thick before allowing skaters to lace up
and says it usually takes about 10 to 14
consecutive days of temperatures below
-10 to reach that thickness
in Quebec the bus driver accused with
intentionally ramming a Laval daycare
with a city bus killing two children has
been found fit to stand trial a
psychiatric evaluation found that piece
is mentally able to participate in the
criminal case the 51 year old will now
be evaluated to determine if he can be
held criminally responsible and whether
he was suffering from a mental disorder
at the time of the incident
the federal government pledged an
additional 30 million dollars in relief
aid for people impacted by those
devastating earthquakes in turkey and
Syria 20 million dollars in funding will
be provided as humanitarian assistance
in response to appeals from the United
Nations the other 10 million will match
donations provided by members of the
humanitarian Coalition which is on top
of the 10 million dollars in matching
donations provided to the Canadian Red
Cross
[Music]
held hostage next why one Ukrainian
Community is unable to risk fighting
back in the Russian invasion
[Music]
thank you
one year into the war in Ukraine there
are fears that Russia will ramp up its
Onslaught and there's one community
living in the shadow of Europe's largest
nuclear plant that is under a constant
barrage of Rocket fire from Russian
forces tonight Jeff Semple tells the
story of a damaged Mining City in the
banks of the danipro river in southern
Ukraine a city that can't fight back
this is martinetz a small Mining City in
southern Ukraine on the banks of the
danipro river but these days residents
are not allowed to get too close to the
River Shore because of the danger that
lurks just a few kilometers away on the
other side Marinette sits in the shadow
of a Russian occupied nuclear facility
the Russian military captured the
zaparisha power station one week into
the invasion firing on the facility
dozens of times fueling fears of a
meltdown
since then the Russians have used the
nuclear plant as an army base to launch
attacks on nearby communities like
marhanets the ukrainians can't defend
themselves to fire back would be to risk
triggering a nuclear disaster
what can I say about Russians Who hide
behind a nuclear power station there are
no words says the mayor of marinets
showed us the aftermath for months of
Relentless Russian shelling hitting
schools hospitals and hundreds of homes
every night you go to bed you're not
sure if you're going to wake up this
resident says we're sitting ducks
foreign
sirens sound warning of an incoming
Russian strike Lydia hold a sheriff of a
Shields her brother with planks of wood
he's partially paralyzed and last month
a piece of shrapnel ripped through his
bedroom the impact of the blast
shattered every window in their house
turning shards of glass into projectiles
can I use swear words a lot of swear
words she says when asked about the
Russian military we need to push them
out as soon as possible
like her brother a lot of people here
are vulnerable or sick those who
couldn't have left months ago around
half the City's population of 50 000 has
fled Out of The Shadow of the nuclear
plant
it's a living nightmare we remember
Chernobyl and this could be many times
worse says this patient at the
marhanet's hospital which is just
kilometers from the power station
even before The Invasion Hospital staff
were preparing for the worst
we have evacuation routes the sickest
patients would be moved to the basement
to avoid the radiation and were stocked
with iodine tablets says the marhanet's
hospital director but of course we
understand if there is a nuclear
disaster the hospital itself won't be
able to help staff here face the daily
dilemma of caring for the sick and
wounded while the hospital itself is hit
Windows blown out emergency rooms and
infectious disease units riddled with
shrapnel
there are no military targets here
they're shelling peaceful civilians the
mayor says my soul is crying we need
humanitarian assistance but this city of
martinets is about to receive some help
from another Community 9 000 kilometers
away in Canada we'll have that story
coming up on the new reality that's
Saturday on global
Jeff Semple Global News martinets
and immediately following the new
reality Global News will Air a half hour
special to mark one year since the
full-scale Russian invasion of Ukraine
that's tomorrow night at 7 30. and
that's global national for this Friday
thank you for watching tonight we're
going to leave you with scenes from
around the world as Ukrainian allies
show their support and Mark one year
since Russia's Invasion began
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other
good night
[Music]